public sénat
[Musique]
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro d' europe et
donnons pas depuis le parlement européen
coronavirus oblige mais nous allons
échanger avec mes invités à distance sur
le déconfinement amorcé en europe 1
déconfinement vous allez loire en ordre
dispersé
et pour en débattre j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir à distance karima delli
vous êtes eurodéputée française
vous siégez au sein du groupe les verts
je précise que vous président présidé la
commission transport et tourisme au
parlement européen et pour échanger avec
vous drague auspices la roue eurodéputés
moment renie où le groupe centriste au
parlement européen
bienvenue à tous les deux tout au long
de cette émission deux autres invités
deux citoyens européens
l'un depuis cambridge en angleterre
l'autre depuis hambourg en allemagne
et bien vous allez nous écouter et
intervenir pour nous faire part de vos
remarques et nous faire partager vos
quotidiens confiné où des confiné mais
avant d'entamer notre débat le point sur
la situation sanitaire en europe face à
la pandémie de coronavirus s'est résumé
pour vous par samia de fuir
à elle seule l'europe comptabilise plus
de la moitié des décès liés aux qu'ovide
le vieux continent est à ce jour le plus
touché au monde mais la pandémie a
frappé inégalement son territoire
l'ouest paix sans conteste le plus lourd
tribut à eux seuls quatre pays
concentrent plus des deux tiers des
décès le royaume-uni l'italie la france
et l'espagne comptabilise ensemble plus
de cent dix mille morts ils ont malgré
tout commencé à lever partiellement leur
mesure de confinement cette semaine
quelques jours après l'allemagne dont le
taux de mortalité est resté moins élevé
que chez ses voisins dans d'autres pays
en revanche cela fait déjà presque un
mois que les citoyens reprennent peu à
peu leur activité l'autriche a commencé
son déconfinement mi avril
comme la plupart des pays de l'est en
voyant la vitesse à laquelle le virus a
frappé l'ouest du continent
ils ont eu plus de temps pour prendre
des mesures drastiques avant que le coc
vite 19 ne les atteignent bulgarie
hongrie croatie à l'est tous les pays
compte pour l'instant moins de 1000
décès c'est également le cas des pays du
nord de l'europe
le danemark la norvège et la finlande
ont déclaré l'épidémie sous contrôle
seule la suède qui n'a pas adopté de
mesures de confinement déplore plus de
3000 victimes
l'europe de l'ouest paye le plus lourd
tribut
l'europe centrale et l'europe de l'est
semble plus épargné plus préservé drague
auspices la roue comment vous expliquer
cette différence entre l'europe de
l'ouest et l'europe de l'est
tout d'abord je crois que c'est bon une
explication c'est lié au fait que l'un
l'europe de l'est
les mesures de confinement étaient
drastiques et je crois que vraiment
d'avoir une situation grave
les isolements qui a été très rustique
mans liées ou non et à des rodéos gens
se déclarer roumanie ou bien d autres
pays d reste de l'europe
bon on aidé c'est ça c'est clair qu'elle
est un délit en allemagne notamment le
taux de mortalité est resté moins élevé
alors on sait qu'il ya eu une vaste
campagne de dépistage est ce que cela
explique tout selon vous non cela
n'explique pas tout moi je crois que
surtout c'est que il chauvelot surtout
dire que la santé c'est pas une
compétence de l'union européenne
pourquoi on la diversité d'impayés
l'autre parce qu'il n'existe pas de
coordination européenne sur la santé
publique et portant des nuits à montrer
justement le manque de cette
coordination c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que cette pandémie
s'est déclaré d'abord en italie les
italiens a appelé à l'aide
et malheureusement ces appels à l'aide
n'ont pas été entendus ce qui est grave
puisque chacun pour soi l'a remportée
par rapport à la solidarité que doivent
les états membres de l'union européenne
alors maintenant par rapport à
l'allemagne
l'allemagne à elle a pris des mesures
qui sont beaucoup plus ambitieux parce
que d'autres pays par exemple elle a sa
propre industrie notamment de
médicaments ou même de masquer ne dépend
pas forcément d'un pays qu'on appelle la
chine
elle a également voulu m
en évidence le fait pour sortir du déni
il faut pas trop peu solution elle se
base sur trois choses tout d'abord un
avoir des masses renoue 2 d'avoir des
tests 3 d'abord délits notamment dans
les hôpitaux
et ces trois règles leur niveau de
l'allemagne où ont été respectés
contrairement à une période où notre
pays prague auspices la roue est ce
qu'il ya une évidente commise par
certains pays dans la gestion cette
crise sanitaire
bon je veux commencer par dire que même
si on peut être d'accord que la
coordination européenne a démarré plus
lentement je crois qu'on peut pas dire
qu'on n'a pas décodé coordination est
l'effet mi avril la commission
européenne a publié la feuille de route
des mesures d'isolement des grands
navires us a donné bon déclar é tait sur
les principaux rassemble des critères
qui doivent être prises et les mesures
qui doivent être prises sur le pont que
vous m'avez demandé
je crois que il y a diversité
en ce qui concerne aller le respect pour
rappeler les règles qui ont été imposées
on peut avoir sa bombe
une en fonction de la culture public de
respecter les règles vont les pays de
sud est les payeurs le plus importante
que dans d'autres c'est ça oui
exactement
exactement visuellement rapport qu'ils
étaient pratiqués au sud
mais des pays comme la cde bien que
confrontée à relativement monde qu'avant
maintenant tendance à cédantes stable
mais est lente mais je crois que c'est
trop tôt pour conclure quel était le
meilleur choix
dragos pis là vous nous avez parlé de
l'intervention quand même plus ou moins
coordonnée l'union européenne même s'il
a été en effet à se contester on a quand
même assisté alisation un show cause
notamment à charlesbourg marque cela a
donné lieu en effet à des vols entre
états membres
karim a glissé sa l'union européenne en
il ya eu des gestes de solidarité on a
vu l'envoi de matériel médical même si
les images sont choquantes ou des pénis
ce bateau tarmac chinois pour pouvoir
récupérer chacun leur masque c'est quand
même dingue mais en europe il ya eu il
est vrai un peu tardivement par exemple
moi je préside la commission transport
liées le transport et l'accueil de
malades français ou autres dans des
hôpitaux a demandé le rapatriement de
citoyens européens qui était le bout de
la terre hop on les a ramenés on a
commencé à s'organiser par une
coordination sous l'égide de monsieur
breton sur le matériel médical a vu
aussi que l'europe se saisisse de la
question du vaccin donc donner des
chercheurs des médecins pour enclencher
cette dynamique de recherche
véritablement urgente maintenant la
véritable question et je crois qu'il
faut remercier l'ensemble des salariés
au style du monde des transports sur la
logistique notamment le volet
alimentaire le volet matériel etc
ils se sont véritablement coordonnées
même s'il ya eu des petits couacs
puisque la véritable problématique c'est
comme il n'y avait pas de coordination
nous voyez un pays à nous de fermer ses
frontières mais pour faire passer aux
marchands
parfois c'est très dit il karima delli
pas de coordination pas de coordination
notamment concernant le déconfinement
amorcé en europe
dragos puis cela vous est ce que serait
pas été souhaitable c'est un peu plus de
coordination sur ces confinement notons
pour être plus efficace peut-être dans
la lutte contre la propagation du virus
alors je suis d'accord
un effet que au niveau européen on de
faire de plus mais je suis pas d'accord
qu'il n'y a pas eu de coordination
peut pas nier les choses qui ont été
faites alors j'ai juste
je ne veux pas défendre la non non il
n'y a pas de coordination sur ce
déconfinement chaque pays a choisi de se
dé confiné selon son propre calendrier
sa propre stratégie layati son
ordination l'union européenne sur ce
développement
mais bon on peut pas avoir une
coordination parfaite parce que la
pandémie de koffi 19 n'a pas éclaté
simultanément dans tous les pays
européens
l'évolution n'a été pas similaires alors
de demander en démon dans ce genre
décoration peut faire alors ça c'était
pas réaliste et la levée des
restrictions a donc commencé à se faire
à différents moments et un de
différentes manières cependant bon et on
a maintenant une feuille de route on a
des délais records bien sûr qu'au niveau
record
on va on ne parle pas de ce genre de
consignation parfaite
alors ça c'est très bien que
comprendrais pas accuser l union
européenne pour ne pas cordiner chose
qui est très liée au site
aulas sur la citoyenneté est-ce qu'il ya
tout de même un modèle de déconfinement
en europe je pense peut-être à
l'autriche où il ya peu de morts
déconfinement amorcée depuis la mi-avril
sans rebond pour le moment des
infections karima delli est ce que c'est
un modèle à suivre peut-être alors je
crois que il faut revenir sur il n'y a
pas de coordination au niveau européen
d'aidé confinement parce que il ya des
pays qui ont anticipé sur voilà nous y
sommes c'est à dire qu'ils ont pris des
mesures de confinement beaucoup plus tôt
ce qui sera organisée sur les masques
etc et ensuite on a eu un problème de
coordination quand même parce que si moi
je prends je ne sais pas le train qui va
des paris à bruxelles j'ai besoin de
savoir si l'érection des voiliers que
dans les transports vous êtes obligés
d'avoir une obligation de coordination
par tour
vous auriez souhaité plus de co2
coordination mais ce qu il ya un modèle
de déconfinement en europe qui serait
que qui pourrait inspirer les autres
pays là en l'occurrence aujourd'hui
pour l'instant nous pouvons pas le dire
parce que tout le monde redoute tu fais
un retour d'une deuxième vague donc moi
je ne préfère pas dire aujourd'hui qu'il
y à des modèles mais ce sont des
secteurs bien eu l'espace public mais
lorsqu'on regarde par exemple les
transporte partout et là c'est quand
même nouveau on voit que même en france
ou dans d'autres villes en europe
la bonne nouvelle c'est à dire que une
mesure qui permet de de respecter
l'éthique cervélo et mme roussel
regarder la rue de la loi qui est la
plus polluée une ville dé les rues les
plus polluées d'europe
on voit bien que désormais la piste
cyclable va être totalement nouvelle
pour aménager tout ça on voit que des
bonnes pratiques un peu partout
maintenant il faudra une feuille de
route qu'ils soient claires je crois que
le temps du bilan pas encore le cas mais
en tout cas il va falloir aussi un tissu
sur ces bonnes pratiques partout en
europe
en tout cas une chose est sûre c'est que
la plupart en tout cas de très
dangereuses et européens ont mis en
place au sont en train de mettre en
place une application de tracking pour
suivre un petit peu l'état du vide mais
il y à des ong des élus ou des citoyens
qui s'inquiètent en d'éventuelles
dérives et quitter ce citoyen de rien
dragos pis la route comment l'union
européenne et le parlement européen
notamment peuvent-ils garantir la
protection des données la protection des
libertés individuelles notamment quelles
sont les garanties vous pouvez donner au
citoyen européen
la position de dénicher chez nous chez
ni europe
nous pensons que l'approché du
développement d'une application de ce
racing bonté l'application doit être
coordonnée au niveau européen
premièrement avec des normes
obligatoires des solides garanties de
respect des droits fondamentaux qui sont
payés
en détails et en particulier les droits
de la vie brisée la protection des
données
bon c'est d'application doivent être
conçus comme des outils complémentaires
est temporaire ça c'est très important
faisant partie d'un plan d'isolement
bien qui comprend en outre des tests et
mesures sanitaires et des distensions
social isolement et l'a40 digne le
développement des traitements et des
vaccins assez rare et pas une solution
qui qui va rester avec la protection que
vous avez karima delli vous êtes
d'accord en quelques en quelques mots là
c'est avec votre collègue du groupe
renault sur ses applications de tracking
je crois qu'il faut aller plus loin
c'est dire que là c'est une question de
liberté individus les écologistes nous
sommes très simple nous sommes attachés
à la vie privée et que pour l'instant ce
genre de dispositif n'a pas encore
montré son efficacité je rappelle et ça
c'est très important que l'union
européenne doit garantir notamment le
détournement possible des telles
applications celles d'hier la première
chose c'est comment va garantir nouma
des utilisateurs comment on va gérer
l'ensemble des données et comment on va
faire en sorte que ces données où il
reste un temps mais s'évapore ensuite
et tout ça pour l'instant nous n'avons
pas de garantie d'accor donc vous voulez
plus de garanties sur ses applications
au niveau de l'union européenne
sanitaire est aussi économique et
financière elle a de nombreuses
conséquences sur le terrain de la
solidarité européenne mais aussi en
matière d'état de droit ou encore de
libre circulation des personnes
c'est un sujet de samia de chiens
[Musique]
la pandémie de kovy 19 donne des ailes
aux eurosceptiques
le 5 mai la justice allemande a sonné la
banque centrale européenne de justifier
son programme de rachats de dette
publique la cour constitutionnelle
saisie par un groupe de citoyens
allemands jugent que ce programme lancé
en 2015 n'entre pas dans les compétences
de la bce et lui laisse trois mois pour
prouver le contraire
faute de quoi la banque centrale
allemande ne pourrait plus participer à
ce programme
la cour de justice européenne l'a
pourtant jugé légal
l'union européenne envisage donc de
porter plainte contre l'allemagne pour
non respect d'une décision de justice
européenne
pas question de laisser ce ouvrir une
brèche qui pourrait appeler d'autres
recours contre le plan à 750 milliards
d'euros annoncée par bruxelles pour
relancer l'économie européenne en 2020
autre règle d'or de l'europe mise à mal
par la pandémie
la libre circulation des citoyens dans
les pays membres
durant le confinement chaque pays a pris
ses propres mesures de fermeture ou de
contrôle des frontières
la commission appelle à une réouverture
coordonnées des frontières intérieures
sans discrimination de nationalité les
frontières extérieures de l'union reste
en revanche fermée pour tous les voyages
jugés non essentiels jusqu'au 15 juin en
europe la pandémie bouleverse également
l'organisation des élections
en pologne les citoyens étaient
initialement convoqué le 11 mai pour
choisir leur futur président l'actuel
chef de l'état andres duda du parti
conservateur droit et justice est
candidat à sa réélection
mais après des préoccupations émises par
l'opposition et l'union européenne sur
les conditions d'organisation du vote le
parlement a décidé d'un report dimanche
les bureaux de vote sont donc restés
fermés une nouvelle date doit être
annoncé d'ici le 24 mai
je voudrais qu'on revienne sur un sujet
d'importance les frontières elles
restent fermés en europe et en dehors
pour le moment les déplacements sont
très limitées ordre on voit notamment
pour une nécessité économique de libre
circulation notamment en vue de la
saison estivale qu'il va falloir
peut-être penser autrement la commission
se penche sur ce sujet à caen à nouveau
la libre circulation des citoyens
européens dragos pis là où bon alors et
c'est clair que la commission européenne
travaille sur cela bon il ya une
stratégie qui est vraiment et rédigé par
la commission sur ce sujet je crois que
les recommandations qu'on va avoir
nous fournit une approche de trois
phases pour la réouverture des
frontières qui a rassemblé les états
membres avec des profils de risques
globaux similaire s'est alors ça veut
dire que l'on peut avoir des mesures de
relaxer les conditions de confinement
une des cantines mans et une expansion
des couloirs verts quant à eux jusqu'au
maintenant et je crois que ici l'agencé
européenne de lutte contre les maladies
ecdc serait rédigée pour conserver une
liste de gens à faibles et circulation
de virus afin que les mesures de
quarantaine jeu 40e général au sein des
chaînes puisqu'on sait être supprimés
est bon les nouveautés se sont que les
voyageurs consulter une carte
interactive est établie par le cdc qui
créera les derniers contrôles aux
frontières mesures et conditions voyage
ça ce sont des ddd des nouveautés qu'on
a on amène à karim a dit que vous
présidez à la commission 33 arrêts
tourisme il est nécessaire de rouvrir
les frontières en vue de la saison
estivale on voit que notamment pour les
professionnels du secteur le demande
sont très inquiètes
la première chose à dire ce que la
commission va présenter tout d'abord une
carte européenne des zones les plus
touchées est désormais moins
touché parce qu'on peut pas bouger là où
ou des zones serait un risque donc je
pense que peut-être l'initiant autour de
principes on aura d'ici quinze jours
déjà une flic ça chantait déjà des états
qui disent on veut bien recevoir par des
touristes français mais les quinze
premiers jours de notre pays ce seront
des jours d'isolement
ensuite en un des pays qui vivent du
tourisme comme l'espagne qui elle
envisage de fermer sa frontière jusqu'en
octobre à défaut d'un accord européen et
d'un contrôle homogène dans les pays
deviennent et rhuys on a aussi les
d'italie qui évoque même pas de
perspective de leur ouverture dans son
secteur qui ont déjà fait le doyen de la
saison en faire un dire de regarder le
tourisme beaucoup plus de proximité et
régionales mais parler des frontières
il profite pour dire un petit mot parce
que lorsqu'on parle des frontières nous
ne devons jamais oublier notamment les
réfugiés qui eux justement numérique
complètement qu'on s'intéresse à eux et
qu'on les accueille je crois qu'on ne
peut pas aujourd'hui parler de cette
question des frontières et qu'on soit
pas capable mais mende accueillir les
réfugiés qui ont aussi besoin de nous
dans cette période s'est dit pour
conclure ce débat et à l'heure où la
commission européenne présente son plan
pour une croissance verte
à quoi va ressembler l'europe d'après
corner en une phrase drague auspices
l'art ou la relance économique
ça doit être une relance verte hop ça
doit être une réouverture et l'ars de
l'industrie et européens aussi une rage
de la transformation digitale que nous
souhaitons vers ans des petites et
moyennes entreprises et les entreprises
de famille et bon d'une autre côté une
relance de compétences pour le futur
pour le marché de travail qui est bon
liêu ou futur que nous attend alors s'il
y a il ya des choses qui sont claires
l'europe doit pas seulement résigner à
ceux qui
or maltais était avant la crise honda
sur imaginé le futur on doit renouveler
le futur rock et on va travailler
ensemble pour cela ça c'est une phrase
ou bien de trois semaines et voilà elles
sont cette question bien je vais
demander à nos deux citoyens européens
leur avis depuis cambridge en angleterre
gregorc raid c'est depuis hambourg en
allemagne
elle loge à faire et nous à faire est ce
que vous partagez cette vision de
l'europe d'après une vision en tout cas
verte et écolo je pense que maintenant
cette époque que nous vivons c'est une
rupture c'est une chance une chance de
repenser l'europe de recenser beaucoup
de beaucoup de secteurs de la société et
de ne pas continuer comme on l'a fait
avant grégoire crif depuis cambridge est
ce que vous avez un mot à dire à nos
eurodéputés ou en commentaire à faire
sur ce que vous avez entendu durant
cette émission surtout leur souhaiter
bonne chance que j'ai entendu beaucoup
de choses qui me plaisent et c'est vrai
beaucoup de gens ici même si même avec
le break s'il est si on peint on parle
de l'europe d'ici quelques mois beaucoup
de gens disent que c'est l'occasion
rêvée pour l'heure de se prouver une
fois de plus on parle de la crise
économique qui l'a frappée naturellement
ça va être l'occasion de prendre les
mesures qui s'imposent naturellement la
crise de la santé autour du virus
l'environnement aussi beaucoup de monde
ici dit ce serait l'occasion rêvée de
faire des progrès de les gens qui m'ont
fait beaucoup plus au vélo ou vous-même
à la marche à pied ici donc si on
pouvait continuer comme ça se serait pas
fait très bien karima delli drago qui se
la roue je vais vous remercie et je vais
vous laisser vaquer retournez à vos
occupations et puis je vous dis à
bientôt j'espère au parlement européen
donc je pense ou au revoir je poursuis
désormais donc avec vous grégoire creps
vous êtes français mais vous vivez
depuis plus de 15 ans en angleterre je
travaillais dans l'informatique et vous
êtes encore dans un pays
confiné suite aux annonces de bruit
johnson il ya quelques jours
comment se passe du coup votre quotidien
confiné à cambridge en angleterre
écoutez très très égoïstement pour moi
ça va pas trop mal j'ai aucun symptôme
j'arrive à travailler depuis la maison
on vit dans une ville comme risquée par
quelques petites était charmante et très
verte donc on arrive en creux sortie il
ya encore de quoi manger dans le
supermarché
donc c'était pas agréable d'être in fine
et naturellement elle met le confinement
est un peu plus léger que ce qu'on a vu
en france au début par exemple c'est
comparable mais on n'a pas à assimiler
de formulaires à chaque fois qu'on sorte
par exemple savez notre test vous avez
un petit peu relâché en quoi est-ce que
vous avez la sensation que les
britanniques ont encore confiance ont
l'art et exécutif alors qu'en europe le
royaume uni et il est plus lourd tribut
en nombre de morts non non justement
c'est cette sainte était la grosse
surprise pour le gouvernement
on a vu la cote de popularité de boris
johnson le premier ministre remonter un
peu au début de la crise mais ça je
crois que c'est partout en europe avec
tous les chefs d'état mais il est
derniers sondages sont effrayants et je
crois que c'est au moins 75% la
population ne font plus confiance au
gouvernement
et comment ça fait de moins en moins
confiance aux médias pour l'information
et qu'avez vous pensé du discours du
premier ministre britannique qui a
annoncé de nouvelles mesures de
déconfinement progressive très
progressive
très sincèrement ce que je pense depuis
le début c'est que c'est un petit rigolo
qui a maintenant perdu pied c'était
facile pour lui de faire des bons mots
de ce fait régner quand la situation est
à peu près comme de d'être sur la vague
du grec si vous voulez jouer la
popularité là dessus maintenant il est
au pied du mur et on lui demande des
résultats et c'est clair que
malheureusement il n'est pas compétent
c'est ça soit au niveau des décisions
prises toute la stratégie de
communication c'est vraiment une
catastrophe c'est pas une surprise que
l'europe sont maintenant le pire pays en
europe
que le clan des terres pendant sur le
pire pays en europe au niveau des morts
on est presque on s'est presque gré aux
états unis d'être encore pire que nous
parce que c'est un petit peu moins moins
humiliant et de la même chose européenne
ont été humiliante parce qu'on a vu que
maintenant même l'italie a pitié de nous
c'est la grèce aussi ses poulains pour
le prestige pour l'amour propre des
anglais ça a été un coup vraiment énorme
on prend la direction d'hambourg en
allemagne où vous vous trouvez et nos
chats faire je précise que vous êtes
directeur d'un lycée et vous nous avez
dit en préparant cette émission qu'il
est plus facile de se confiner que de
ceux des confiné exprime pourtant les
épreuves du bac on devait vous en
allemagne et notamment dans votre lycée
oui absolument alors il était assez
facile au début deux de tirer le fusible
c'est à dire d'arrêter tout comme ça
d'un moment à l'autre
tous étaient et ah ben non pour
redémarrer c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
par exemple les restaurants maintenance
et de hambourg parce que selon les
länder les régions c'est très différent
de les mesures de déconfinement mais
heureusement c'est aujourd'hui que les
raisons boeuf offrir hambourg dont mais
sous des conditions de deux dixièmes
par exemple on ne peut on peut servir
seulement la moitié des des tables ce
qui est difficile pour les pour les
restaurateurs parce qu'ils n'arrivent
pas à combler leurs frais dans les
écoles c'est un peu pareil maintenant on
va offrir les écoles pour toutes les
classes mêmes eaux que des groupes et
des petits groupes de 15 de 15 élèves ça
veut dire que tu es faut diviser la
classe sont eux-mêmes trois groupes
c'est à dire ouf et découvre traité à
part
les cheveux ou mais de façon pédagogique
ne donne pas vraiment de sens et ça
c'est difficile ce que vous avez dit oui
on a on a organisé des examens du bac
oui sa fonction sociale en effet on l'a
vu sur vos photos que vous avez envoyées
dans des gymnases avec des bureaux bien
espacé l'allemagne se dé confie l'un
vaut mieux dit est ce que vous craignez
une seconde vague alors que certains
nouveaux foyers de contamination
apparaissent en allemagne dans certains
cantons
contrairement à la majorité des gens en
allemagne je ne suis pas expert on voit
maintenant beaucoup d'experts qui est ce
qu'ils cherchent les microphones
moi je ne suis pas je ne sais pas de
dire aujourd'hui je bois or je n'ai pas
beaucoup peur mais aujourd'hui j'ai lu
un article du robert koren si toute
notre institut de de santé qui dit que
dieu on reste dans des déserts est
responsable or on peut peut-être même
éviter une seconde vague mais il ne peut
pas le dire très bien on vous compter
sur la responsabilité individuelle de
chacun ce seront les mots de la fin
merci beaucoup à tous les deux pour
voter manioc âge c'est la fin de cette
émission vous pouvez la voir et la
revoir sur notre site publicsenat.fr
mais également sur l'antenne de la rtbf
et on se quitte sur ces images le
concert à l'occasion de la journée des
70 ans de l'union européenne un
anniversaire un petit peu particulier
dans une europe encore confiné à très
vite pour de nouvelles aventures sur
opel